[Music]
hey everyone it's brandon from the other
vegan meat eater video um i edited this
episode and i really loved working on it
i think you all will really enjoy it but
before we get started the jubilee family
just wanted to say hi
enjoy the episode
i just don't really like dinner
what's the reasoning
i think we should get on a different
subject though
we brought together seven meat eaters
i'm a meat eater i'm a meat eater i'm a
meat-eater i'm a meat-eater i'm a
meat-eater
one is a vegan if the group discovers
who the liar is they'll split a cash
prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
who is the odd one out
[Music]
hi everyone thank you so much to you so
what kind of music are you guys into
these days just just curious why would
you ask that yeah like what is vegan
music i actually got a real quick
question what did y'all eat for
breakfast this morning
what do you eat for breakfast just bacon
i eat cereal dairy milk um no but
i don't drink dairy milk that's like
yeah why don't you drink dairy milk
though because i don't like dairy it's
just gross to me
do you eat the cheese yes
i literally ate a breakfast burrito at
beechwood cafe yesterday i have a
question how would you guys just find um
veganism missing out on all the good
stuff
no really i'm a little bit confused
about plant-based versus vegan because
can there be meats that are plant-based
if i'm not mistaken
i don't like the fruits
actually
the things that you eat right um
diet-wise and then vegan's more of a
lifestyle yeah how do you like to cook
your meat um i just got
an air fryer so i kind of just throw
everything in there let it do its thing
seemed a little suspicious to me because
my mom's vegan and she throws her tofu
into the air fryer so i
kind of connected the dots i just can't
cook for my friends because if they're
vegan i don't really know what to cook
[Music]
he was very cautious and his matter of
speaking even his body language was kind
of reserved as well
she kind of gave me rachel berry vibes
and if someone would were to be a vegan
it would be rachel berry lovely girl
lovely girl
[Music]
am i seeing everyone
i'm a little bit confused what would
give people the impression that i was a
vegan maybe in their head they're
thinking like hipster you know white
girl oh you're going to follow this
thing that's kind of popular uh one more
time because you said you don't eat
dairy what's your reason i know you
don't like it but what is your like real
reasoning for i
really don't have a reason i just prefer
like oat milk and everything like my
lattes and stuff like that when it comes
to milk when it comes to milk
what's the reasoning because it's like
if you could have authentic real milk
like what's so bad about it the way you
choose your alternative
you look very suspicious right now i
mean and i noticed she started
backtracking you know trying to defend
herself i
love oat milk but i was not gonna
advertise that and look what happened
and i wouldn't if i was actually the
mole i wouldn't give myself out like
that you know like
i don't know why
that might be your strategy
like just a minute i'm just saying a lot
of people don't eat dairy even if
they're not like being vegan is
i also have like almond milk and oatmeal
i think we should get on a different
subject though
how did you cook your chicken okay
i had six chicken thighs near both sides
pour broth and rice into it low and slow
low and slow six thighs just for you or
yes i am crazy about chicken pies
chicken's my favorite bro okay i have a
personal question
once in the morning
one or two times so i asked the poo
question because vegans have a healthier
diet healthy diet healthy digestive
system more healthy poop
how many times a week do you find
yourself eating meat constantly
literally i'm a delivery driver for
amazon so i don't really have time to
like cook because i get up early in the
morning right so really i just buy food
on my lunch break all the time
chick-fil-a and canes is my go-to man so
i work at a steakhouse funny enough but
i always get hooked up with the chefs as
far as meat has anyone tried being vegan
i'll say because i'm hawaiian mexican my
ethnicities don't really allow me to be
vegetarian i have but i always fail i
last like a day i'm being honest why
didn't you try to be vegan is my
question when was the end of that i only
lasted a day it was like years ago and
mainly to be healthier i guess
but it didn't work out
it's got to be hillary she flipping the
script she don't want to answer
questions she don't like barry it's
clearest thing she the vegan
mia said that she tried to be vegan for
a day just for one day and she kind of
looked like a vegan to me
she was managing the q a but not
answering any of the cues and she had
like a her fit was very it gave bougie
vegan
we counted all the votes and we have a
tie the tie is between
hillary and mia
you have 30 seconds to deliberate and
choose one person to eliminate
okay so mia said she used to be vegan
why wouldn't you want to try it again
agree that's right i agree 100 with you
but hillary be way too quick to keep
changing the questions
i'm also suspicious of hillary but she
could just be a lady chicken lovin
do you think she likes six times
why don't we go for one and then yeah
yeah
which one first
and the person eliminated this round is
mia
sorry miss girl
you made the right decision
if everyone feels confident that you
already caught them all you can end the
game now but if the majority has doubt
the game will continue please raise your
hand if you want to continue playing the
game
starting now for every time all of you
vote out someone that is not the mole
the total prize money will be reduced
okay
we're not allowed to do that
i have a question for kyle and maui so i
feel like when i think of vegans
typically you kind of get like the
leaner look so
you know what do you guys do for fitness
what does your like day-to-day food look
like
i'm just an unhealthy person i know meat
gives you protein but i have a very fast
metabolism this is which is why i eat
six chicken thighs um in the evening and
that's all you eat is just chicken
thighs i mean i switch it up i get wings
i get chicken sandwiches all you eat is
like meat then well
yeah
who just eats like chicken thighs and
chicken thighs and chicken thighs the
satisfying feeling you get from just
biting in to a juicy chicken sandwich
the popeye's chicken sandwich for
example just it's a wave of euphoria
it's very orgasps
let's circle back to maui the vegan
vibes defend yourself
i get that a lot how do you get a lot of
your protein
protein shakes
a lot of chicken
steak so you said protein shakes first
instead of meat
okay i have an interesting question i
know vegans are against skinning animals
alive not alive but
the general skin of animals so are those
real leather they are uh yeah i'm pretty
sure doc martens are mine are real are
yours real
no i don't know this is all done
can we check i'm pretty sure yeah
wait you're going to be driving really
quick
is this real leather or is that fake
didn't even see the jacket probably fake
what temperature do you cook your meat
too um
i buy the pre-cooked meat the tyson
grilled chicken things meat just cooks
mine is pre-cooked
[Music]
we formed a small alliance when we
agreed to vote mia out so next step was
to vote hillary
i voted for kyle just because he said
that he ate chips
six chicken dies every single day which
i didn't really believe
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all are gonna be losing money
sorry
please raise your hand if you want to
continue playing the game
okay majority card
i just didn't believe it was any of the
girls that were vegan we tend to
stereotyping be more into veganism
health and all that than men so i feel
like the men were kind of picking out
the girls first come on man
kyle or maui
if the lights turn green that means you
have voted out the mole and you win if
the lights turn red that means the mole
is still in the box and you
lose
[Music]
you're the mole
it's you
will the vegan please step forward and
reveal yourself in three
two
one
[Applause]
all right uh well anyway i've been vegan
for four and a half years the reason why
i became vegan more so because i always
felt weird about eating animals in the
first place but also my ex-girlfriend's
dad died when she was 13. she felt like
he might still be alive if he had a
healthier lifestyle so she's actually
the reason we started it but the thing
was though really it's not so much the
meat that y'all love to eat it's more so
like the flavors and the textures so
really when you get creative with your
plant-based diet though you can really
create food that tastes just like it if
not better i still love chicken i just
don't eat real chicken you know what i
mean this is our thanksgiving special
episode so we wanted to surprise all of
you with a vegan thanksgiving meal
[Music]
i hope it tastes as good as it smells
and looks
[Laughter]
i love it it tastes like a mcchicken and
i love make chicken there you go there
see now you see there's hope
i'm thankful for all the new friends
that i've met since i moved here from
colorado i'm thankful for my help i'm
thankful for you guys
i'm thankful for the opportunity to be
here on jubilee i am thankful that
things are starting to look a little bit
normal again and there's hope for the
future i'm thankful for this little
window into veganism
all right i'm thankful for the art of
cooking you can make anything possible
whether it's vegan or not vegan it'll be
delicious
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
we want to thank you and give you a
little gift
thank you i like it
shout out to
the the media's shout out to i've been
preached jubilee watch
my mama pookie and ray ray tyler perry
i'm looking for a job shout out to jesus
the most high just happy to be alive and
make a little bit of money y'all you
know man you believe baby
[Music]